[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
number is it 62. it is 62. wow i'm
amazed i got that right in light of
where we are
things are moving at quite a pace in the
world
and i must say in some ways this could
be exactly the thing that the dark horse
podcast
leans well into you and i are two adults
with a certain amount of expertise in
the world and a certain amount of
experience and
we can talk things through and people
seem to find that rewarding
on the other hand it's very hard to know
how to even process what's going on so i
must admit i
personally am feeling a bit
discombobulated
and off-kilter even though at some level
everything that is taking place not in
its detail
but in its general in its general
valence
has been predicted by us and others
um in numerous places so
i don't exactly know why i'm so
surprised i think it has to do once
again with the
incredible speed right that is to say
even when you predict that some process
is going to happen
you can be caught completely off guard
by how quickly
it unfolds and there's something
something important in that
indeed um i'd like to start though with
some gratitude great and actually um
and and just point out where we're going
today
uh although much much of what we're
going to be talking about today is
exactly
responsive to uh some of the main events
that have happened this week which puts
you know it i think it's much more
within your both wheelhouse and interest
space
and i was hoping to talk about sea stars
this week
um i don't think there will be time but
perhaps give me a second wait
i got the connection okay then you will
you will give me i mean you know
my enthusiasm uh my new renewed
enthusiasm for sea stars as of this week
and the shocking revelation which you
brought to me i this one
uh i didn't see coming right so so maybe
we'll get there maybe we won't but
um i will i want us to start with some
words of gratitude and end
actually by talking uh by providing some
words
uh from the great uh buddhist monk
tiknot han on fear and what its impacts
in the world are
from his book of the same name fear uh
from 2012 in which he is
as usual prescient in the middle we're
going to talk a whole lot about
the lab league hypothesis and its entry
into the mainstream conversation
and of course the events at the capitol
on january 6th
and the resulting events with regard to
censorship in social media and
really tech space in general apple
google the whole bit
but but first we
it is now january 9th it is now actually
all parts of christmas are now over uh
we have been informed we've been
educated as to
uh the the epiphany ending oh boy i've
already forgotten is it actually the
sixth it might be
um epiphany uh the the um
christmas the 12 days of christmas oh i
didn't know this term
uh so uh it is over
but we because of delays and shipping
due to
covid and overburden shipping and such
we ended up receiving
a number of things from from darkhorse
fans to our post office box
and uh that we just received this week
and i and
we wanted to say in response to your
gratitude thank you as well so
uh we received many many cards including
um people's christmas cards that they
were sending to their friends and family
and they thought
you know why not send them to us and
they're really wonderfully appreciated
including
um not least the one that on the back is
printed epstein didn't kill himself
we received that one today actually i
would say festively printed festivally
printed
yeah i i laughed out loud that was good
i liked i appreciated that
um we got cookies uh and even though due
to delays they were
they arrived rather a lot later than
they were shipped they were
delicious um we received some wine we
received and we have no idea who the
wine is from
exactly i would love to know yeah so if
if that is in fact
uh one of y'all we'd love to know who
that is because there's no indication
right and i would say um the wine was
excellent not a great match with the
cookies you need a little
rarely break there but um yeah although
as we were drinking that we have only
drunk one bottle of the wine it was a
french wine and
uh upon putting it down for a while i i
picked back up my glass and i said i
detected a little sugar cookie
in in the flavor profile of the wine so
that's true
you should not be drinking the cookies
with the wine but sometimes you can find
essence of cookie in the wine yeah
exactly even if no one has
surreptitiously dipped their cookie in
your wine when they weren't looking
so you know that seems um perhaps
trivial
cookies wine etc but but no
especially now when we see ourselves our
entire society the world
and even within families fracturing and
splintering
and you know decohering in so many
ways it is ever more important to
recognize
the acts both large and small of others
that reveal our shared humanity and our
appreciation for one another
so we really we really appreciate that
what we're doing here
is being responded to with enthusiasm
and gratitude and
in turn we are grateful for you yes um
so i'm i'm going to just uh wing a
little addendum to that terrific um
you know we are working once again
without a net
because once again she didn't show up
for work never never
she is um not a hard worker actually but
in any case um i would say there is
something delightful
about people um revealing their
gratitude and i don't want to say this
is just about
gifts or anything but it is so nice when
people
alert us that what we're doing is
meaningful
to them right i mean even just to know
that a small number of people
find it a significant fact in their week
that uh it makes them feel better about
the world more grounded all of these
things
is incredibly rewarding and it is also
uh
fascinating and marvelous to see when
people
um you know put their creative
uh energies in motion and generate art
pieces
which go onto our walls and uh and other
things so
sorry i should have mentioned this that
those those things didn't happen to come
in the last week or two but we have
received some
amazing art from people and maybe at
some point we should perhaps
you know photograph and share some of it
but really truly wonderful
wood carvings and some some sculptural
pieces
uh really remarkable beautiful stuff and
i would say there's something in it you
know
i think this should be obvious and
probably the conscious part of it
is but there's something um that's
easily lost where
human beings because of the way the
modern world works don't
get an opportunity to be important
to each other very easily right it's
just not an opportunity that exists in
people's lives so
people tend to become frankly covets
made that even harder it has made it
even harder although
i've seen lots of people you know
pioneer new ways of reaching out too so
you know it cuts both ways but i think
the thing is
you know were we hunter-gatherers
or were we you know pastoralists uh you
know
carving a living out of the the earth or
whatever the various
uh recent or more uh deeply ancestral
ways of being that one
could have found themselves in the
you know i think the common experience
would have been
to be important to a small number of
people in your town or
in your tribe uh absolutely and
that there's something just so
alienating about a style of life
that in fact just doesn't offer that
possibility um
because you know most of your time
you're preoccupied
with earning a living by you know doing
things that aren't important to you
because somebody else will pay you to do
them and may in fact you know often
are not important to the world or even
bad for the world but serve
you know some small number of people's
bottom line you know a profit motive of
a few people as opposed to doing
serving any greater good yes i'm
reminded
actually uh i find david graber a mixed
figure he died this year um you know i
didn't know that yeah he died so
few words about who he is uh so he
actually was very particular about how
he was described
um i think what he said was something
like
um anarchism is not something you are
it's something you
do and so he didn't like being called an
anarchist so he clearly had those
leanings
and i must say i don't share those
leanings with him
though you know as anarchists go he was
a pretty sophisticated thinker
he was i would say uh you know jesus
this is uh
you know people do not like it when
you're honest about the dead but
um he was atrocious when it came to
evolutionary analysis he just got it
really really wrong
on the other hand his article
[ __ ] jobs was really quite
spectacular and it made the point that
what most people
do cannot really be explained in
even classical economic terms right that
basically we have a society that
preoccupies people on
uh nonsense that's so ephemeral it's
hard to imagine why it's even being done
so for if if i were listening to this
and never heard of him before some of
the words i'd like to hear to inform you
of who
he is before you say more about him is
um that he was
i believe a professor of anthropology
and that uh
the work by which i came to know about
him was this
massive book called debt um and in fact
i looked it up as debt to the subject
the subtitle is the first five thousand
years yeah
uh from ten years ago yep um
so he's doing sort of an economic
anthropology um
of of the history of what it is to
exchange for humans so he was
he was a professor and um he was also a
founder
of the occupy movement so anyway all of
these things paint a kind of a picture
but
something about the [ __ ] jobs
article which was quite a short
to the point piece i'm sure it's easily
findable
uh you know speaks to the fact that
there's just something about the way
this amazing machine-like thing that we
call civilization
sidelines our humanity and sets us about
other things and you know
at some level you may not have a lot of
choice about whether or not you're
employed as a cog but it certainly makes
sense to notice that that's happening to
you and maybe to
take up arms against it yeah and the um
the legitimate feelings of frustration
and futility
which can manifest in illegitimate ways
we've been seeing
from the so-called left all summer and
fall and
on wednesday in the capitol we saw from
you know maybe it's the actual right
maybe the so-called right
and it's it's emerging from a similar
human
place and by saying that i'm not in any
way justifying the behavior of the
writers on either side
but the there's legitimate sense of
futility and lack of connection
because because we are living such
disconnected anonymous
lives which raises a couple of things
that i should probably
mention somewhere in here uh i was on uh
trigger pod trigonometry um this week
uh talking about the events at the
capitol
yeah they live streamed with you on
thursday the day after the events right
yep
uh it has been pretty widely circulated
and anyway we talked
a bit about the fact you know in some
sense one place that one should stand to
understand
what's going on is that there
is massive frustration
around some vague sense that something
is way off that
the system is not functional and many of
us
including me certainly believe that the
system is rigged
i believe that it is rigged in many ways
that are
legal and that that's not a defense of
of those things
um it is certainly sometimes rigged in
ways that are illegal
that we get hints of which of course
means that there is no end
of uh false conspiracy allegations and
it's very difficult to sort between
which ones
are valid and which ones aren't valid
which of course
requires a skill set that at some point
we should um
talk about and we have talked about you
know we've talked about the fact that
you know the word theory and the more i
think about it
the abuse of the word theory is at the
heart of so many of our dysfunctions
that really as annoying as it is
to have um you know these semantic
concerns brought to the fore
in the midst of a crisis in this
particular case if we were careful about
it if we just
simply agreed across the board hey
theory has a definition
hypothesis has a definition and we are
all
obligated to just sort of stick to them
and not blur that distinction because
it's a really important one
we would be way ahead in so many
different places
from i mean i agree with your point
about the abuse of the word but i don't
think that would help right now
i i don't i don't think that's
fundamental enough to the problem
uh to you know i don't think solving the
language problem would address
any serious issues at the moment well i
think it would
in the sense that to the extent that one
wants to convince you of something and
cause you to act and they invoke the
term
theory because it carries power right
to the extent that somebody making a
analogous
argument uses the term hypothesis
they've already told you what rules
they've signed up for
when somebody says they're involved in
critical theory
i don't know what rules they've signed i
mean i don't i don't think this is where
we want to spend time today really but
i will say that pretty much anyone
hearing the word hypothesis does have
the sense of what it means but that
theory has been so abused that you know
you hear people saying oh well that's
just my theory
that's you know and so you know it means
everything and
without the counterpoint hypothesis i
don't think it actually carries the kind
of weight that you think it does
and i'm not saying that that hasn't
hindered the conversation
um when you know conspiracy theory is
the word of the day as opposed to
conspiracy hypothesis but i don't think
resolving that actually um helps us much
but i i think we should move
oh i just want to make the point that um
we are dealing you know in so many
different realms with the downstream
consequences of this right where we have
you know
string theory effectively owns modern
physics
and the question is it is
jumping it is not even a hypothesis in
the sense that we don't have any
predictions from
and so to the extent that it has
effectively taken over
a field and the point is it has taken
over a field from a very weak position
um you're not you're not telling me
anything i don't agree with
we disagree about whether or not this is
the important conversation to be having
right now i just don't think it is
all right uh i will uh continue to to
fight this quicksand you can beat the
drum i just don't think that drum is
going to rise to
the top of the importance ladder all
right that's not everything
that didn't make any sense that didn't
work uh
it worked well enough i mean for you
know for live
internet uh discourse i suppose you were
gonna say something about david graber
i think or maybe well i was going to say
um that
this was really a riff on your um
your bit about gratitude which is that
many people have arrived at the
conclusion
that there's something wrong with human
interaction and one thing that seems to
be wrong
is that our ability to find ways to be
important to each other
is just severely curtailed and you know
you and i
are lucky in the sense that the modern
uh era has delivered us tools to be
important to a lot more people than we
would ever
meet under normal circumstances that's
pretty cool
right but the point is it's also just a
weird and very arbitrary concentration
of a kind of
value where you know we can tap into
reaching a lot of people whereas most
people have a hard time reaching
anyone just because of the economic
realities of
of modernity so anyway thank you for
alerting us to the fact that we um are
doing something positive in your lives
and um the gifts are very very
meaningful and
we do spend time thinking about each of
them yeah
and sharing them with our children who
one of our children is obviously
hard at work in the other room clicking
away making this podcast happen
that's right all right so there's a
question about where we should go first
and i think
the first place to go is um
or second place to go is to talk about
the
progress with the lab leak hypothesis
that occurred
in the last week yeah i believe well my
notes uh suggest in which a conspiracy
hypothesis
is accepted by the mainstream with no
acknowledgment that that is what has
happened
and yes this was published uh in
the new york in new york magazine
on why is there no date fascinating oh
january 4th
2021 so yeah in within the last week
january 4th so
roughly a lifetime ago by nicholson
baker called the lovely hypothesis
yes and it's quite good um i mean maybe
zach should
put it up yeah i think he should i sent
him a link to it zach you want to
it's also on my screen if you want to
show it there okay
um so this article is very very well
written
and it covers a lot of the people that i
hold in high esteem who have been
both courageous in discussing the lab
leak hypothesis
including yuri dagan who was on the dark
horse podcast
um and some others who i've become aware
of who
have bucked the academic trend and
talked about
this and what it does is it takes the
lab league hypothesis
and it legitimizes it so that now
anybody
can discuss it and the reason that this
is so
important is that we have this
period between which it was obvious that
there was something to discuss
and the mainstream has effectively been
forced to admit that
and that period is going to be lost to
history i have a feeling but its
significance is
uh hard to overstate and i mean i am
flabbergasted that this is a point that
needs to be made
but when you say there is a period
during which uh between
which it was obvious that there was
something to be discussed and now it's
entered the mainstream and so we're sort
of allowed to discuss it and this is a
period that lasted
well more than half a year
because we we began talking about on
this podcast in april
of 2020 what you said
is exactly right but this nuance which
is not really nuanced will be missed by
some people
it is obvious that there was something
to be discussed what you have said is
not it is obvious that it is true
this is in fact your distinction between
theory and hypothesis
right that the idea that it is a
possibility that we should be
considering on the table
as opposed to we've got an idea that is
true
it's that this is a you know this there
was a an animal
in the market in wuhan and that's what
that's the origin of this virus
that is the only thing we're allowed to
consider at the point
back in april may june etc of last year
that you had scientists no less
credentialed scientists
working as scientists earning their pay
as scientists who said
there was one and only one possible
explanation for where this virus came
from and for you to think anything else
is irresponsible
that right there is anti-scientific
because what scientists do
is they observe something and they say
what are all the possible explanations
for this thing
and lab leak was obviously a possibility
from the very beginning and by saying it
was obviously a possibility is not
saying it was obviously true
saying it was obviously a possibility so
it was obviously a possibility
and interestingly you can see
it was captured in my twitter feed
exactly how early it was obvious that it
was a possibility
and so the percentage likelihood
that it was the explanation for for the
pandemic
has changed for for me and presumably
for everybody
uh checking in with that idea but zach
do you want to show the um
screenshot of my twitter feed from
february 4th
screenshot of my twitter feed from
february 4th seems
really specific um
so there are two screenshots here boy
can you put that on a bigger screen zach
okay so um
i will just start telling you what's
here and uh
okay so let's just set the stage here
for a second heather
you and i were in the amazon this is
february 4th 2020.
february which was like less than a week
after we got back from ecuador i think
i was hoping you'd know the exact date
offhand maybe you don't but
that we left the amazon the date at
which we went from being completely
without communication in
the in yasuni in ecuador
to returning i mean cell phone reception
again
becomes possible at the military
checkpoint um
when you are transitioning back to the
town
affectionately known as coca that's
going to have been january 24th
january 24th okay and then we came back
to the cut to the u.s on january 28th um
so the
fact of the corona virus what was then
called novel coronavirus
was unknown to us while we were in the
amazon we
emerged and at uh while we were in
otavalo
um in the andes in the andes uh
decompressing
and getting ready to return home
literally decompressing given the lower
air pressure up there
so yes we were decompressing in the
andes uh
looking at hummingbirds and all sorts of
other stuff but
uh in any case we emerged from the
amazon the world had begun to grapple
with the idea of a novel coronavirus and
you know
if you think back to where you as a
listener were
to the novel coronavirus at that point
you know there have been a number of
these
um emergent viruses you know
sars and mers and bird flu and things
like this and
um you know so there's always this
question about oh no there's this virus
that's been spotted what's going to
happen is it going to take over the
world is it going to burn itself out
and so it's very hard to tell at the
point that we caught wind of the novel
coronavirus
how bad it was going to be there was a
nature paper
and is that what you're referencing here
and what's on screen here yes it was a
nature paper that outlined the
um the wet market hypothesis and the
fact that it had been
uh the virus had come from bats and i
thought as a bat researcher
i thought it made sense for me to look
at this paper i'm always a little bit
troubled
when diseases are associated with bats
because people don't know how to
calibrate it there's so many species of
bats and yes bats do vector a lot of
diseases because they fly and therefore
they're good vectors
but you know people don't understand you
know
the little brown bat in your backyard if
you're listening to this in the united
states is not vectoring
these diseases right it's not likely to
and it's not likely to carry rabies
either though that's a possibility
but unlikely unlikely but um in any case
the um the fact is the viruses are the
enemy of the bats too so in some sense
we're on the same side and i i don't
like to see bats demonize but anyway i
thought i would look at the paper
i would read it it said you know batborn
coronavirus
wuhan seafood market and i just thought
i would weigh in and say
i've looked at it it makes sense to me
and i did
and that was at 10 30 in the morning
of february 4th and
i immediately got pushed pushback from
followers
who said oh so it's just a coincidence
that there's a bio
uh safety level four laboratory studying
bad coronaviruses in wuhan where the
virus emerged
right i think a fact about which you
were previously unaware
completely sure and i thought
that's a hell of a coincidence there's
probably something about the story i
don't know
at least i need to understand why that
coincidence is
not stunning right that piece of
information
puts this hypothesis on the table as
something that obviously needs to be
considered
obviously needs to be considered and as
yuri
dagan pointed out when i talked to him
and as i
thought one of the things you need to
know you know i wasn't really
deeply thinking about what a bio safety
level 4
laboratory was and i had no idea how
many of them there were
you know if there were a thousand such
laboratories and the fact that there's
one in
wuhan may not be significant it's just a
coincidence
you know if there's one and it happens
to be in wuhan it's a spectacular
coincidence and it happens
there are a handful but that one of the
two
primary ones studying coronavir batborn
coronaviruses
in wuhan is certainly a stunning fact
and many many of us
who are on the heterodox side of this
question
have had this exact same experience
which is as soon as you realize
that wuhan is the location of such a lab
that it was studying exactly these
viruses and it is the
first place that humanity becomes aware
of this virus you know that there
if you're an honest broker you know that
there's something that has to be
considered yeah
so this um this paper this article this
magazine article that's out this week in
the new york magazine
uh cites a piece from 2012
uh is published in the bulletin of
atomic scientists
which i would love to read just the
first two paragraphs from because it's
directly relevant sure so 2000
um sure if you want to it's on my screen
it's called the unacceptable risks of a
man-made pandemic by
lynn klotz and edward sylvester for
those of you looking i don't know why
the first paragraph is partially
replicated so i'm reading the first two
paragraphs even though it looks like i
just skipped one
now that world attention finally has
been focused on the potentially human
contagious h5n1
asian bird flu virus remember this is
written in 2012.
the international research community
should take steps to deal with three
other potential pandemic pathogens
two are among history's nightmares
smallpox which killed or made
millions of people over centuries that
ravaged the world and the resurrected
1918 pandemic flu virus
which may have killed 50 million people
worldwide over just two years
the third is severe acute respiratory
syndrome or sars a newcomer that proved
how lethal it could be in one natural
outbreak during 2002 and 2003
when it killed 9.6 of those it infected
a fatality rate almost 4 times higher
than the 1918 flus
these potential pandemic pathogens or
ppps
pose a danger that goes well beyond the
potential of other hazardous microbes
that have made the news
the ppps are all extremely deadly highly
contagious or potentially highly
contagious in humans
and not currently present in human
populations meaning it would be a
disaster to reintroduce them into the
population
of the three smallpox researched at only
two facilities
in the world by international agreement
poses the smallest threat of laboratory
escape
at russia's vector and the u.s centers
for disease control lab workers have
been vaccinated to prevent infections to
themselves it might spread to others
outside the lab
in stark contrast to the strict controls
on smallpox research however
sars the 1918 flu virus and potentially
human contagious h5n1 bird flu
are studied in laboratories throughout
the world using less than the highest
biocontainment known as biosafety level
4
or bsl4 and there is no approved and
stockpiled vaccine for
any of them so
yes the there is awareness of the
hazard which in fact resulted in an
intense effort to study bat corona
viruses and there's also been
a competing awareness of the danger of
studying them and in particular of
studying
using techniques called gain of function
research where
viruses are enhanced to see what they
will be like when they become
truly infectious uh which and the
hypothesis the lab leak hypothesis
i think for all of us who have tracked
it carefully is not
uh there is a version of it in which the
virus simply ends up in a laboratory
and unmodified escapes from the
laboratory into the world that's a
very unlikely to be true because the
virus that would have ended up in that
laboratory
would not have been highly transmissible
between people and if there's one thing
you can say
about sars cov2 it's that it is highly
transmissible between
humans right it's a trick it's very very
good at him so the question is where did
that happen and while possible
the idea of this virus happened to be in
a lab that was unmodified
is less parsimonious than this virus was
out in in the wild
and transmitted without having an
intermediate step in a lab
right well there one would expect an
evolutionary
period in which the virus either picked
up a skill
through recombination with some other
virus so time to evolve without human
artificial selection
right so you there's a number of things
you would expect and we have evidence
for exactly none of them
right it doesn't have a long period of
time in which it learned to go from
person to person
it doesn't have you know many people
have hypothesized things like
pangolins and other intermediaries um
but there's no evidence that this
actually occurred
so anyway there's a there's a whole lot
of mystery but what i wanted to point
out about these screenshots is that they
actually happen to document
a thought process and give it a time
stamp so
february 4th 10 30 i
tweet i have looked at the nature paper
cited here and the evidence
that the novel coronavirus came from
bats possibly rhinolophus a finis
uh or another species sorry it's at a
distance that's hard for me to read it
or another species that shares roose
with it
is fairly compelling how it jumped to
humans is less clear
but wet markets are likely okay that was
10
30 by my next tweet
which was 11 1129 i said
several followers have pointed to a
competing hypothesis and the nature
paper does not allow us to distinguish
between the two
the virus likely comes from bats that
much is true
the bush meat trade is dangerous also
true those
things may well be unrelated in this
case now my reference to
the bushmeat trade is obliquely about
hiv which the best explanation for how
hiv ended up in humans
is um basically chimp
butchery that resulted in the virus
transmitting to a human
um so in any case
that's less than an hour by one minute
right
the between year two between my two
tweets
the fact of the uh bsl4
lab in wuhan is sufficient to raise the
skepticism
of an honest broker thinking in a
scientific
mode it didn't mean that it was the
probable answer there
now the irony is as the lab leak
hypothesis
has been defended by courageous people
willing to take the risk of being
dismissed as conspiracy
theorists or trump loyalists or whatever
it is that the accusations have been
as that hypothesis has you know
clawed its way into uh
grudging acknowledgement by the
mainstream that it is something
that reasonable people might consider
the explanations
that were offered as official have
fallen
right everybody including china
acknowledges the wet market had nothing
to do with it there weren't bats for
sale there
so the point is the other hypotheses
have crumbled even as this one has
gained steam
right now a person could have
a wild conspiracy theorist that is to
say somebody who
is not exerting any sort of analytical
discipline could have landed on the
right answer here
and they would turn out to have been i
won't say right because we still don't
know that the lab leak is what happened
but would turn out to be in this
credible position almost by accident
right a person who was methodical and
careful and just simply following the
logic and the evidence where
it led would have ended up here too so
you can't really distinguish those two
things
but over time one of these hypotheses
has gained ground because it is
impossible to refute so far
and the circumstantial evidence is very
strong there's no direct evidence but
the circumstantial evidence is
incredibly strong
as we iteratively fail to falsify a
hypothesis
it looks ever more likely to be an
accurate representation of underlying
reality
right and what's more if it turns out
lab leak is not the explanation
all of the things that we will have
learned in the attempt to falsify that
hypothesis
are now basically a description of what
a better hypothesis would have to
explain
in order to take the lead right and so
people will remember back in
would have been june or july
i said that one of the ways to deal with
this stuff responsibly
is to rank to give a percentage
chance that you think some possibility
if you have competing hypotheses what
you think the percentage chance is and i
made a little flow chart and i went
through all of the things that i could
think of that could possibly explain
where this virus had come from and i
ranked lab leak as very high something
i think this was far earlier i think
this was may frankly may have been
anyway may have been may but in any case
there's a way to do this and there's a
way to do it responsibly and the amazing
thing is when you do it responsibly even
when you have
you know a credential that uh means
that somebody has agreed that you have
this the
toolkit with which to do such a thing
even then you face these amazing
appalling accusations
of being a conspiracy theorist
right um being irresponsible spreading
uh
false information um you know i mean
even uh
peter dashik who it turns out was
central to the funding pipeline that
resulted in the money that
allowed this coronavirus to be or these
coronaviruses to be studied in the wuhan
lab this guy with this incredible
conflict of interest right
he was leveling accusations of
conspiracy theorists against anybody
including us for
for talking about this stuff so
the point here is two things and as
usual you know follow the actual
conflict
it's easy to accuse people of having you
know having secret
financial connections and some people
presumably do
or being grifters or whatever but when
there's a known conflict of interest
by someone who is accusing other people
of
spreading information for which there is
no support but you can actually point to
the support or the failure to falsify
well then the conflict of interest
speaks really loudly
yes the conflict of interest um uh is
deafening at some level and in peter
dashik's case it's just amazing
how far he has gone to
ridicule and erode the credibility of
anybody who even raised
this possibility in public
but so this comes up here for two
reasons
one this is the week in which this
hypothesis has become mainstream and
suddenly
you should expect a very different level
of conversation about it because
effectively people have been signaled
that it is now
safe to acknowledge the obvious right
safe to acknowledge
the obvious now how many topics do we
face
this kind of situation why is it ever
unsafe to acknowledge the obvious ever
gosh i just have this image of someone
like peering out from a storm cellar
door is it safe to acknowledge the
obvious
right is it safe to acknowledge the
obvious is it is it safe
you know to acknowledge that men and
women are different phenomena
you know well we'll get back to you
right not all that's safe at the moment
maybe we'll get there
um but the question really and
the interesting thing this is just
happenstance that this arises in the
same week as the
uh insurrection at the capitol and if
need be i will defend that word
um in a moment here but um the
insurrection of the capital and what may
be much more important which is
the downstream uh at least
narrative consequences so things have
been moving
incredibly fast in the last day
and ostensibly that is the result of
the uh the invasion of the capitol
building
some of it can't possibly be i i
frankly didn't have enough time in
becoming aware
of the fact of a new anti-terrorism bill
that is ostensibly the result of
uh responsive to the events of the
capital um
you know i wasn't able to look at it but
this can't possibly be
responsive it has to have been uh ready
to go in large measure
and then you know some giant many many
many page bill that was
that someone is arguing was created in
response to what happened on wednesday
uh
number i have seen was something like 20
000 pages now that could just be
a rumor i'd like somebody to validate
that i went looking for it and
time ran out on me uh before the live
stream but nonetheless yes
there does appear to have been a lot of
stuff ready to go
and then the events of the capital seem
to have created pretext
for it to be unleashed and
um what i so what i want our
listeners to do is to keep
what has happened with the lab leak
hypothesis
and then what has you know the latest
chapter is it has gone mainstream i want
them to keep that in mind
as they try to grapple with what is
taking place
ostensibly as a result of an egregious
breach at the capitol building
all right so um all right how to put
this in context so what has happened
just for the sake of catching people up
there was a rally encouraged by the
president
at the capitol now this rally was
apparently
much larger than most people understand
the number of people who entered the
capitol building was relatively small
the number of people who were president
present in this rally was quite
huge and we are in the awkward position
we have been working in fact overnight
trying to get
um processed and ready for release an
interview i did
yesterday with jeremy lee quinn who
people will
remember i interviewed before jeremy lee
quinn happened to have been
in washington at that rally as a
journalist
and actually went into the capitol and
witnessed
what took place firsthand and what he
has to say
is quite shocking and quite a good
corrective to
the narrative that um that
is is circulating so that very long
conversation that you had with an
eyewitness journalist to the scene
uh should be up uh both on youtube and
as a podcast
uh momentarily frankly youtube is
telling me that video processing is
taking longer than expected
so youtube is
telling us that video processing is
taking longer than expected
i don't know what to make of it probably
video processing is just taking longer
than expected but
in any case please do take a look at
that
interview i think you'll find it
fascinating and i think you'll find it
very hard
to dismiss as
resident in some part of the political
spectrum the fact is
uh jeremy lee quinn uh is a
uh a progressive lefty self-described
uh pacifist anarchist um i'm a
a person of the what i would call the
intellectual
left and here we are you know discussing
uh people who were decidedly on the
right who breached the capital
uh for many different reasons um you
know it was not
one of the things we talk about is that
it was not a coherent
um uh event that people had you know
there were people there
who were engaged in what they thought
was a coup
and there were people there trying to
prevent what they thought was a coup
right and they were somehow in the same
uh the same protest so it's a you know
it's
an event that really requires people to
think very carefully about
about what its nature was and
indecipherable from one another in
photographs
presumably right and in fact um you know
i do think
there's i haven't been able to put my
finger on exactly how to
think about it or phrase it but there is
some interesting
yin yang you know the anarchists
uh the antifa black bloc anarchists that
we have seen
rioting all summer uh
make an effort to de-individuate and
they you know they become the black bloc
right and this is about uh not
displaying their identity now if you
pay close attention it's clear that to
them they do have identities and that
you know so they still can earn cred
with each other
um but from the point of view of the
outsiders it's just a bunch of people
wearing
so much black that you can't deduce who
they are whereas
in the insurrection at the capitol you
know you have a dude in a
viking helmet i mean something
yeah it's it's so there was a whole lot
of um
it's basically uh a
much more libertarian uh perspective
and the fact that everybody you know i
was i didn't not aware that
in the insurrection there were you know
grandmothers
trump supporting grandmothers who
entered the capitol didn't know that
um so you know you've got dudes and
viking helmets you've got
grandmothers you've got people carrying
the confederate flag
um you know it's it's not a clear
message it's it's a bunch of different
frustration but
at some level well it's not it's not
coherent um
and you know in in this way i think uh
there is something
in many ways there is something
analogous to the protests which reliably
became riots that were taking place
in portland almost every night for well
over half a year
and in other cities as well with some
less regularity
in that there are
you know and you know the treatment
obviously from the media of these these
two sets of events is wildly wildly
different but in both cases
it is not a single uniform group and so
just as people on the right um decrying
every single person who went out into
the streets to support black lives
matter
were wrong to do so because this was not
a single
unif uniform force and not by far the
vast majority of people
who were protesting on the streets uh in
in portland for instance and elsewhere
did not become rioters
but a reliable portion of people almost
every night did
and um it sounds like i don't know what
the ratios are we may never know but
you know just as there was some rally uh
that
uh that included a wide variety of
people
most of whom had never had no intention
of and would not have gotten
wrapped up into uh what you're calling
an insurrection
you know siege on the capitol um but
that doesn't mean that some
small proportion of people didn't do
that and in both cases the rioting
whether or not it's on a federal
building in downtown portland or the
actual capitol building in washington dc
is totally unacceptable oh completely
unacceptable
now one does have to deal with
and i talked about this on the
trigonometry
podcast one does have to deal with the
fact
that the united states was born in an
insurrection
and so there is an acknowledgement in
our
you know our foundational principles
that there are there are events
that uh call for something
well beyond civil disobedience in fact
um can we just
show very quickly here zach my screen uh
wall street journal
op-ed from uh three days ago actually
from a former princeton fellow
as well aaron zubia called the founder's
guide to knock down drag out fighting
the sub title the sub-headline here
being the ratification debates of
1787-88 were colored by quote patriotic
enthusiasms verging on violent chaos
again not a justification just an
historical
correction of sorts uh that are
our rosy image of history as if the u.s
was born
uh you know sort of aphrodite-like on
the half shell
and everyone was thrilled with it is
certainly not true yeah
certainly certainly not true but you
know
so i i will say this whole conversation
takes place uh with a certain amount of
you know i'm tempted to say trepidation
but let's just call it fear
there's a certain amount of fear that
what is
taking place on the major platforms
is coming for us and that the
important points that we are trying to
make will not only be
lost but that are
attempting to make them may hasten
what will likely come for us not for the
first time so we will come back to this
but um
but in any case i wanna i wanna somehow
make this point and to the extent
that darkhorse might disappear from
this platform i want you to remember
that i made it
okay and the point is
you have a lot of people responding
to a garbagey understanding of what is
taking place
right you have the q anon right
right which has a misunderstanding about
where we are
not that they're i don't know almost
anything about the
detail of the content of q anon but it's
an
overly packaged view of what has gone
wrong it has
filled a vacuum of information about
what really
runs society this is
again the counterpart
of the confused understanding over on
the blm antifa
uh black bloc left right which has the
sense that
our civilization is so evil and so
far above others with respect to um
how much harm it has done that the only
response to it
is to tear down its structures right
that that cannot
possibly make things worse and will
inevitably make things better that is an
equally confused understanding of where
we are and so
you cannot have a society in which every
individual gets to decide
for themself when you have reached a
moment
that you are obligated to rebel against
the structures and tear them down
right you can't have everybody waking up
each morning and deciding whether
they're in a unabomber
mood or not right so to the extent that
the founders of the country
rebelled against a tyrannical governance
structure they were
very clear-headed on why they were doing
it and they were
united and it was clearly justified and
what we have here
is a small insurrection into the capital
that is somehow the fringe i mean it's
almost
physically the fringe of this much
larger protest that was at the capitol
which is itself
the fringe of the conservative movement
right so anyway you've got these things
it's like a physical
gradient and you've got people who are
you know
wearing the viking helmets and carrying
the confederate flags breaching the
capitol that's obviously completely
unacceptable
and uh and it is an insurrection even
according
to many of them right you'll see this in
in
what they say into cameras um
however i think it is also incumbent on
us to recognize
there are some very i know nothing about
the improvised explosive devices that
were we are told
were um found at the capitol
i did see an image of somebody who
appeared to be
a a protester who had
zip ties of the kind you would use to
bind somebody's hands these are
very troubling facts as
are the confederate flag the
camp auschwitz t-shirt um
you know these are hallmarks of
something
uh completely out of control
on the other hand completely unhinged
on the other hand what i didn't see
these are right-wingers were any of them
armed
i assume they must have been but
one did not see a lot of firearms in the
circumstance so
what you have is an insurrection a an
egregious violation
of the law one that is not justified by
our circumstances
but done in a way that is clearly
intended to be
in some sense symbolic right so
i'm not justifying but what i'm saying
is that a honest broker would have to
parse all of this nuance and that
unfortunately
what we are getting this idea that we
can decide what
who's right enough to listen to that we
can take anybody
who is engaging any idea that has been
formally dismissed and tossed them off
platforms and things is going to result
in the worsening of the problem
that caused the rioting this summer and
the worsening of the problem that caused
the breach of the capital which is
people don't have good information to go
on why don't they have good information
to go on
lots of different reasons including
mundane algorithm stuff
but but the point is this is what
happens
in the vacuum of analysis is you get
this kind of confusion you get q
on confusion on the one side and antifa
confusion on the other side
and if you want this not to characterize
the way we are
going forward the thing to do is not to
try to police speech online that's a
perfectly insane response to this it's
going to make it worse
the right thing to do is to let those of
us who know how
to engage these difficult questions
responsibly
do it will we make errors of course but
that's the nature of
civilization so may i speak a little bit
to
someone else who we know online
who i think is engaging these things
responsibly and i don't always agree
with her but i just want to share
some of one of caitlyn johnstone's most
recent
pieces here zach just briefly share so
this is
a an independent journalist um who
publishes on medium
and uh she's done several pieces in the
last several days this one called the
boot is coming down hard and
fast so excuse me if i have my screen
back zachary
thank you the very final paragraph of
what she's written here
is the correct response to a huge
section of the citizenry doubting an
electoral system that we've known for
years is garbage
would have been more transparency not
shoving the process through and
silencing people who voice doubts and
making that entire faction more paranoid
and crazy
this is um in a piece which she begins
by pointing out that biden was in fact
the original framer
of what would become the patriot act and
uh in alongside that fact she provides
as caitlyn johnstone the journalist
who's written this piece
provides us a um a clip from an
appearance on morning joe
with the cia cia analyst and former
times now
house representative alyssa slotkin who
is informing us that the real battle
against terrorism is now inside
america's border
she says quote the post-9 post-911 era
is over
the single greatest national security
threat right now is our internal
division
the threat of domestic uh terrorism the
polarization that threatens our
democracy
if we don't reconnect our two americas
the threats will not have to come from
the outside
and one i find excuse me
totally appropriate response to this is
from a woman named whitney webb i don't
know her
who tweets slotkin again the
current house representative who was a
cia analyst
webb says before congress alissa worked
for the cia and the pentagon and helped
destabilize the middle east during the
bush and obama
administrations what she says here is
essentially an open announcement
that the u.s has moved from the war on
foreign terror to the war on domestic
terror
this is terrifying and
um we you know we should be considering
that you know as you i don't i have not
seen this this bill that you have
referenced
i don't know anything about it uh that
has apparently been produced
in record time right um but it is likely
to be something like
back in the mid 90s biden produced
something apparently right before
actually the oklahoma bombing um
produced something
that was you know put up there taken
down sort of disappeared
and then repurposed effectively as the
patriot act after 9 11.
you know where did the bill that is
being trotted out right now
start and by whom and to what purpose
hopefully we come to know the answer to
that one more thing about this though
i'm sure you have
a lot to say returning to representative
slotkin's claim of two americas
i think this is actually a further
divisive and dangerous
formulation and it's it's it's old
right you know we're this two-party
system there's red and blue
there's republicans and democrats but um
i at least
see no evidence of there being two
americas i see a much much much more
fractured
fractured state and at the very least we
have three
you know at the very least because when
when trump ascended there were many in
the republican party who said no way no
how am i never trump or i'm not going
there
and similarly as the democrats have
become
woke and intersectionalist and embraced
frankly the
the riots on the streets of america and
um
and uh you know other nonsense
uh there are many of us on the left who
have said that's not my left
uh i still consider myself uh of the
left but not that way
and so you know we have talked often
about
finding much common cause and many
common values but disagreeing about the
current state of where we're at
with regard to reasonable people on the
right there are a lot of recent people
on the left
who disavow the sort of antifa black
bloc stuff and there are many reasonable
people on the right
who disavow you know beowulf you know in
in the capital
and um that makes at least three
americans
and formulating this as two americas
if sen effectively a hundred percent
says that if i start to critique antifa
anyone else gets to say well then you're
in the america that embraces
trump and if someone on the right says
i am criticizing trump then they are
therefore in the antifa camp no
it's not america is not antifa versus
trump no way
no how that's not the america we live in
and if it is
we're doomed but that's that's not what
we see you know there there are
there are i still believe a majority and
i hope it's a strong majority of people
who are actually in the vast middle
identified as left or right different
views on how to solve the problems we
have
fine but not antifa not
insurrectionist at the capitol something
far more interested
in actually collaborating and coming
together as a country
all right the two important points that
we
have to cover
[Music]
in reference to what you're describing
okay so there are two americas and there
aren't and
how to describe this so we know and we
have frequently talked about the hidden
tribes report that says there's
67 percent of us that are in broad
agreement about
uh essentially nuanced non-extreme
versions of
the answers to all of the problems that
are supposed to divide us uh
irreconcilably irreconcilably
that is clearly true and for you and me
we have had
the gift of our you know our
the story that brought us to public
attention has put us in contact with so
many people
on the center right that we know for
sure because we have met
them hundreds and hundreds of people
right
who we are supposed to be on the other
side of an unbridgeable gap and it turns
out actually we are in broad agreement
and we have to
search for things that we actually have
substantial
disagreement over so that thing is real
what is
also real is that narratively speaking
it's almost like i'm imagining
there's some substance that you can drop
into a room full of people who are in
that vast exhausted middle described by
the hidden tribes
and you drop that thing in and
they simply polarize to other sides
because narratively speaking we
are two different americas right they're
not the same place and so
the fact of having an exemption from you
know
we can cross no man's land and not get
shot at in fact we're more frequently
shot at from our home side
than from the other side which often
embraces us with
you know curiosity if you know not a
little
bit of perplexity but but whatever right
being able to transition across this
boundary tells you oh yeah that that
uh agreement is real but the other thing
and there are humans on the other side
there are humans yes in fact there are
humans everywhere most of the people on
the other side
are every bit as recognizable and yes
they're confused but it's
where is the quadrant where people are
and the extremists on both sides are
are the ones that are difficult to grok
and reckon with
right they are um they are
driving the system and they are causing
the narrative to be
unreconcilable or irreconcilable okay
the other point that i want to make
so there are two americas and there
aren't is one the other point i want to
make
is that every time i hear the word
terrorism invoked
it sends shivers down my spine and the
reason is because i know it is a legally
special word it has been
made into a legally special word and
what it causes to happen
is the suspension of all of the
protections that would normally be
afforded to people and so here
zach you want to put up that screenshot
here is
the washington post and i would remind
you that the washington post is a jeff
bezos property which connects it to
amazon which is connected to the cia i
have no idea what that has to do with
what they do and don't believe and what
they do and don't publish but
nonetheless
was one of the most terrifying sentences
yet today well yeah it's a rough one and
the thing is
i want you to pay close attention i
didn't say that i have an understanding
of what goes on inside the washington
post and why all i can say
is that it's not hard to connect the
superficial dots and that just like
the fact of a biosafety level 4
coronavirus lab in wuhan forces you to
ask the question the connection
of the washington post to uh you know
intelligence is one that it raises
questions maybe there's some perfectly
satisfying answer but i don't know it
um in any case invoking the term
terrorism
causes all sorts of species have you
read for people who are just listening
what this
headlines are so the headline says what
happened at the capitol was
domestic terrorism lawmaker uh and
experts say now again
under normal circumstances what we would
make of what happened at the capitol
i don't think it's terrorism now i did
call it an insurrection
right and insurrection is the most
serious of crimes but
you know i actually made this point in
an article that i think was
so long ago i don't even remember i
think it was published in common dreams
after was
and my point was look terror
is a tactic it's synchron
is that an entity that doesn't have the
military strength
to hurt you does have potentially the
ability to make you hurt yourself
if it can spook you enough so the reason
that terror is at the center of that
word
is that terror causes you to behave in a
way
that is self-destructive much like a bee
does not have the power to kill you but
it might have the power to induce
you into an immune reaction that might
kill you b you said
yeah okay um you know the b doesn't have
an interest in doing that but the point
is
if you know it's not the bee sting that
kills you it's your immune reaction to
it that kills you
if you die from a bee sting terrorism
is psychological it's a it's a psyop
right
and so the point is you know people can
be
induced to doing self-harm through
fear now the question is is what
happened at the capitol was that
designed to induce
fear in americans i don't think so
it was an insurrection but it was not
uh you know it was not designed to be
terrifying and that thing
means i believe that those who would say
it's obviously terrorism and what
they're really saying is
you agree it's very very bad and
therefore it's terrorism and i do not
agree that that which is very very bad
is inherently terrorism
right um you know to to the point uh
this representative slotkin who seems to
be suggesting that we need to move away
from considering outside forces as the
biggest threat to the u.s to considering
inside forces
add to that the observation that
researchers say in quotes that most
domestic terrorism is from the right
and you know in what way is that
established i have no idea but i can
guarantee you i don't have much faith in
those methods
that if you know these researchers are
the same ones who um
turn the splc into an organization that
has
no credibility anymore then you know on
what basis
are a bunch of organizations being
called
domestic terrorist organizations on the
right but not on the left there's
probably
almost certainly political bias there
therefore
if we are being told by representatives
that the biggest threat is coming from
the inside and it has already been
established
in quotes through pseudoscientific means
but trust the authorities
that most of that domestic threat from
the inside is from the right
well then it's not hard to get to
therefore we need to be concerned about
the threats from the right
and and that's it perfect now
for those of you looking for balance
i can't remember when it would have been
but somebody may find it
they will recall that i also blanched
when
antifa was accused of being a terrorist
organization
now i blanched at it for the very same
reason i would point out what i said at
the time was i remember
when uh occupy was taking place and
i will speak only for myself i
participated in occupy
i should have bailed on it earlier
because it got taken over by anarchists
with whom i had
no agreement but nonetheless as a person
protesting the tarp program and too big
to fail and the financial crisis and all
that led to it
to have the government say oh these are
domestic
terror this is a terror threat right and
therefore avail itself of all of these
extraordinary
exemptions and tools was truly
frightening and i don't like seeing that
weapon pointed at anybody who isn't an
actual terrorist
now the argument with respect to antifa
and black bloc
is stronger i believe because in fact
it's not terror in the sense of a big
explosion that causes people to
misunderstand the danger that they
themselves are going to be blown up
but there is marching through
neighborhoods with lights and yelling at
people
like breaking windows waking people in
the middle of the night
and harassing them does induce fear so
at least
you know there's some sort of connection
but again
i think the thing is hey that's a magic
word terrorism is a magic word and when
you hear people invoking it because it
then justifies the next thing that they
do against somebody that maybe you don't
like
boy this is the moment that you need to
stand up and say actually what are you
doing
and so is there i mean is there sort of
a russia wrestle conjugation
uh analog for terrorism that we could
slot in here i'm not sure i'm not sure
there is i'm not sure there's a simple
word
that we can use instead here well
i mean unfortunately what there's gonna
require a little bit more language
yes i think the thing is there are a lot
of terms for things
that don't rise to the level of
terrorism right but
no like big category that can be slotted
in at the same level of
inclusiveness yeah i uh
i don't think so and i so i think the
answer is it's actually
it's a category that either applies
narrowly
to those who would avail themselves of a
tactic that causes people to
miscalibrate a hazard to themselves
and overreact so for example you know
uh the 911 attacks killed 3 000
americans and we lost more than 6 000
people
fighting on foreign battlefields and
spent
uh you know many more dollars
in fighting off those terrorists and
then the harm the terrorists were able
to inflict
but watching buildings collapse
was distorting right it's very hard to
calibrate
how serious a threat the people who were
able to make that happen
were to the us and so in some sense we
reacted
uh in a way that did you know i'm not
we reacted in a way that did more
measurable harm to us than the
terrorists were able to marshal
right we can talk about whether or not
the harm we did to ourselves was
worthwhile obviously what happened in
iraq was an abomination as a result of
the fact that it was under false
pretenses et cetera the whole thing
that that was just a lie yeah but in any
case um
so terrorism is a special word every
time you hear somebody invoke it you
really need to ask the question
whether or not they're invoking it
because the thing that they're pointing
at is clearly terrorism or they're
invoking it because of all of the things
it allows them to do next
and that's the thing that worries me um
most yeah are you communicating or are
you
uh creating a tool uh giving yourself
power with use of a tool that you will
then use in ways that we can probably
foresee but we will not be able to stop
once you've invoked the tool
right now this brings us to the
final piece which is the
breathtaking purge of people from
social media that has uh been taking
place
please i don't know exactly how many
hours it would be but
since sometime yesterday there has been
a breathtaking purge
that purge has included the president
it has included the president not only
um
in his private account but his official
presidential account and every other
account he would
attempt to use to communicate and this
has been of course
cheered by all sorts of people who uh
you know see only um if this is bad for
trump then i like it
um who are of course somehow forgetting
that censorship that you like is always
followed by censorship that you don't
right i either they never learned about
the rosian veil of ignorance
or they've forgotten the lesson but my
goodness
is this going to be used in ways that
you don't like
down the road and there's a question
about why why it's happening in the way
it is of course many of the people who
are
being tossed off the major platforms
are conservatives and the problem is
that lulls a lot of people who are not
conservatives into imagining
that um whatever is going on is
is an academic concern because it won't
come for them but right
um let me point out a couple things
about it one is that could you put up
the
screenshot of the articles of unity
account
so this is a screenshot from today of
the articles of unity
twitter account the articles of unity
twitter account was the official account
of the unity movement
that at the time was advancing a plan
to fend off both the republicans and the
democrats
and put the presidency in the hands of a
left-right
partnership team that would be above
politics and non-ideological
and actually patriotic actually
patriotic the three characteristics were
uh capable courageous patriots that was
qualifications for the job now i feel
like a few of those people still remain
a few of those people still remain they
do but here's the point
if you think that this censorious
instinct
of twitter and facebook and google
is about people whose beliefs we all
understand
to be an asthma wrong dangerous
etc then you need to grapple with the
fact that
it is only months ago that these very
same
entities took up arms against
a decidedly non-partisan non-ideological
effort which you may have liked you may
have disliked it but the point is
they availed themselves of the right to
close down this account
why did they do it well they said we
violated the rules
we went through an intense investigation
to find evidence of what they had said
we had done it wasn't there it didn't
result in them on suspending
the account it remains suspended so this
account was suspended
without a justifiable explanation and
remains so to this day
right that tells you something now i
wish we had
more examples there are a few but
i wish we had more examples of a high
profile so that people could understand
that while it's going to tell you what
it's doing is getting rid of dangerous
conservatives who are espousing views
that will cause people
you know will cause harm what it is
really doing
is getting rid of people that are
inconvenient
for it and yes many of those people are
conservatives but it is not
in any way the thing that is at the
center of
these purges and and the overton window
of what is inconvenient will of course
shift
the overton well it will be shifted to
whatever
is convenient and i would point out hey
zach can you put up the facebook
the tweet about facebook
okay so here is another case this is not
about articles of unity officially
but viewers will remember that my
facebook account which i barely used at
one point i was a
user of facebook but walked away from it
largely
after the evergreen debacle facebook
tossed me off said that they had already
done an internal review that there was
no
going back that i was permanently uh
having my account suspended
i raised a ruckus publicly which brought
down a lot of heat on them and then they
gave a preposterous explanation and said
i had triggered algorithms that were
looking
for inauthentic behavior um
and they were sorry now where you know i
learned this on
twitter i never got any official
communication or anything
now okay that's without your audience
you would have had no recourse
right okay so i have you know 400 plus
thousand
twitter followers that allows me to
generate a fair amount of heat but the
point is the very same weapons are
directed at people who just don't happen
to be lucky enough to have that many
followers and so they remain suspended
and
uh our good friend jordan greenhall has
been suspended
from facebook without explanation i
believe he remains suspended
um the dr rollergator satire account was
suspended
for uh saying it was caps wasn't it
suspended for using it was suspended for
not using his indoor
voice i mean crocodiles never used it
yeah
they don't have an indoor voice um i
don't know what the pretense was i'm not
sure that he the guy who runs the
account ever found out either
well they there were some tweets they
wanted him to remove
but tellingly the very things
in those tweets that they claimed
violated their rules were quotes of
other accounts that were still up and
had not been suspended
for saying them so anyway a completely
preposterous and inconsistent
explanation um but uh oh when i
zach do you wanna so this also is not
just about tech platforms
you want to show the harper's screenshot
so this i have not had time to delve
deeply here i learned about this just
before
the live stream this person was fired
shortly after
writing this article for harper's i
started reading it
this is from 2018.
i'm missing something well it says 2018
archive 2018.
i hope i'm not making an error here
uh she's talking about in the url
i just i so walter kern is an excellent
writer and he used to do a lot of the
opening essays um i don't know anything
about
um this story at
all um but anyway you you may
i don't know what you're gonna say about
this i don't know about this story
raising a question i don't want to make
a mistake
uh if if i'm uh
getting wind of something now that is
actually not relevant to our current
situation
but even if this story is not what i
thought it was
we have at least one case of a
musician being cancelled by their
their record company the record label
for apparently the crime of holding
conservative viewpoints
so anyway what are we to make of all
this well a couple things
one i would point out we are living in a
completely novel circumstance that is
not anticipated
by our constitution and we are forever
caught in the following
bind we hold
freedom of speech as a high value
but we are arbitrarily held to the
protections that were delivered to us by
the founders
who could not possibly have imagined a
world of tech platforms that would
control
um the equivalent of uh paper and
ink and right they they
only knew to name the press in the first
amendment for instance well they knew to
protect us from government incursion
which they saw as the most dangerous
uh threat to the freedom
of uh of exchange and
the problem is and this is the place
where conservatives
inevitably trip up which is
okay free speech is important
why it's important because it is the
mechanism through which
we hash out what is true what we must
consider
it is basically the realm in which
nuance is dealt with there's a ton of
garbage in speech probably most things
that are
spoken are garbage but the point is you
cannot separate out the fact
of heterodox speech
from nonsense speech there is no rule
you can apply there's nobody with
expertise good enough
to surgically separate the two so that
what you're left with is the high
quality heterodoxy
and uh you are freed from the noise
right
it can't be done it's not a job that can
be done in light of the fact that it
can't be done we have to be free to talk
about anything and everything and then
in retrospect we can say what the
important heterodoxy
was so just simply the idea of free
speech is important
okay once you have the idea that free
speech is necessary to the functioning
of a society like
ours especially one in which consent of
the government is the basis of
legitimate
government then the question is how do
you protect it
and the fact that the founders protected
us from government incursion and didn't
protect us from private incursion is
just an accident of history the fact is
the heterodox speech
needs to be protected in the environment
in which it takes place
and conservatives will very frequently
say well these are private platforms
they're entitled to bar people as they
will
and the answer is actually this analysis
doesn't hold
for one thing they're private platforms
in a sense
but they are traveling on an internet
that we
publicly financed the construction of
right what's more they function as a
public square
especially in the era of coven i mean
even more so and we will go back to a
moment
in which we can actually convene in a
public square but
they they are for many of us the only
thing we've got
well even at the point that the public
square is again the public square
the public square doesn't have the scale
right in order to allow us to have a
conversation at the scale at which we
need to be governed
right and so the idea of these private
concerns having absolutely arbitrary
rights
to interfere with anybody's speech
including the presidents and yes the
president can hold the press conference
but you know where will that press
conference be seen how many people will
get wind of it you know in effect yes
there's a technical ability
to um just you know you can shout out
your window and if people really want to
hear you maybe they'll
you know come stand outside your
building but that is
not a meaningful a meaningful challenge
to the control
that the tech platforms now have and i
would point out that in effect
what conservatives are very likely to
leap on which is the
um essentially private property rights
that are the basis of the argument that
if you
own a platform you don't have to let
just anybody speak on it you know and
obviously
that's true at one level if you and i
started a you know a small
you know mom-and-pop publishing house we
don't have to publish anybody who
you know wants to throw a manifesto our
way
but these things are functioning in a
different way they they although
twitter and facebook and google are not
monopolies
individually because each one has the
other in its sphere together they
effectively function as a monopoly
and they are acting in concert here to
limit the access
of certain voices to um the audience
right and i mean
one one piece of evidence to that point
in the last 72 hours
is that the uh conservative leading
alternative to twitter
parlor has had its app removed
by google from whatever the equivalent
of the google you know the apple store
over in google is and apparently apple
is
likely to do the same thing from the
apple store so
uh at the point that uh that there is
a competitor to twitter um but it has
an ideological bent that may be the
mirror image of what
twitter's ideological bent is at least
in terms of what the ceo is willing to
do and say the fact that other big tech
is willing to step in and say no we
won't distribute we want we won't
facilitate this thing being out there in
the world uh
that that looks like collusion yep
and uh it looks uh you know it's not
actually in terms of the legal meaning
the legal meaning of the term monopoly
it's not monopolistic but it's it's a
kind of de facto monopoly
it's a defect it's a de facto monopoly
and the fact that you don't have any
diversity
about political leanings of these
gigantic
platforms and you know tech companies
you know the
the idea that you know apple and twitter
because they uh are traveling in the
same political circles
can act in concert oh twitter's going to
shove you off twitter
maybe you go to parlor and then apple's
going to shut down parlor
right so the point is yeah it's
functioning as a monopoly
right and if the law isn't caught up to
it then we need to fix the law but
that's not what's happening what's
happening
is you've got the blue team
which is now in control of two of the
three
official branches of government right
it's in control
of or will be in control of the
executive
and both houses of congress the courts
are
still potentially independent but this
this reduces
checks and balances well that's an
interesting use of the term independent
what you mean is
um you know red team
i don't really mean red team i just mean
not so you're not talking about the
supreme court particularly you're
talking about the courts across the land
there's a diversity of political
leanings of the judges
uh precisely because the judges um
you know as in scotus but specifically
across the land
have been um are appointees
or have been voted in
by electorates across many many years so
um actually have diversity of politics
they potentially have independence
and um i just i'm i'm curious i'm not
sure why using the word independent when
you say
there's democrats here and then there's
independence like it just seems like a
strange
because bifurcation what i'm seeing is
an unnatural
uh alignment on the blue team it's not
there's no natural diversity of opinion
it's not like
google is um sympathetic with democrats
but holds a strongly free speech
position
and you know twitter is uh much more
interested in censorship
so i mean we just you know we we want we
need
checks and balances in the system and
you are arguing
that it seems like the courts
writ large still have enough diversity
that they effectively can act as checks
and balances perhaps if you know
if need be as you go up towards towards
the supreme court
but uh that there is very little
evidence for
checks and balances at this point as of
you know the end of january
executive branch legislative branch
big tech academia
etc well so this is this is what i'm
getting okay i think the courts are an
unknown how effective the courts can be
in uh holding back the
blue team's power grab which i think is
what we are watching
unfold in real time remains to be seen
but what i would point out is that this
view
that there are three branches of
government and that's where checks and
balances come from
has only one of the branches potentially
independent
enough to exert a check and what we have
is
effectively de facto new branches of
government
now that's a very imprecise way of
saying it but we have
things that exert power as if they were
branches of government that are
unanticipated in our founding documents
and so
um you know it's a little bit naive to
think that you know the
three branches of government and one of
those branches remain retaining enough
independence to exert a check
is sufficient in a world where in effect
which you have
is executive legislative judicial but
then you also have
the so-called fourth estate the press
which is on the blue team
you have academia which is on the blue
team
you have the deep state dare i say it
which appears to be on the blue team and
you have big tech
which appears to be on the blue team now
so just you know
you're going to get clipped but um
you've been talking
about deep state for well over a decade
yep and it was um challenging and
irritating
at the point that trump showed up on the
scene and started
using that language um often imprecisely
as a sort of a political cudgel um
rather than as a patriot and you know
we're
well over an hour and a half at this
point i think so we should really be
wrapping it up but do you
i feel like if you're going to use that
phrase in the current environment you
should
spend a minute or two saying what you
mean by it
um what i'm saying is that there is some
entity which is not accountable by
virtue of the fact that it doesn't
it's not transparent so we can't see it
and it's not accountable
and it is um you know it is the reason
that we fight over
um you know things like uh
snowden and uh and assange and the
uh the things that they have alerted us
to um
but anyway there's something which
doesn't transition
with uh the shifts in belief structure
there's something
that um maintains a presence
administration after administration and
so anyway you know we can argue about
the details of it but i think it's
it's hard to argue about the fact of it
and
in any case
[Music]
it is a powerful force and it's one that
is not anticipated in the constitution
the constitution could not have
understood the
high-tech world of espionage and what
would happen
when you empower these um
you know these uh organizations
to start uh you know breaching and
bending laws
you know in the interests of the nation
what they ultimately end up doing and
you know
we've seen all kinds of shenanigans like
the um
you know the five eyes mechanism for
escaping the protections that u.s
citizens are supposed to have
from government surveillance right this
was just a simple
uh shell game which was if the u.s
government
is forbidden to spy on its own citizens
but it is allowed to spy on british
citizens and the british
are not allowed to spy on their own
citizens but they can spy on american
citizens then there's an obvious trade
right
okay that evades the protection that was
supposed to be there
and you know it exists so anyway i don't
want to belabor the point all i would
say
is the founding documents are not in a
position to protect the values that they
correctly highlighted
and the reason that they're not in a
position to do it is because the world
has changed
radically and so the fact of the
judiciary
may be having the power to check a
you know the other two branches of
government which are now going to be in
the hands of the same
party is reason for hope but it has to
be
placed in the context of yes but there
are these other forces that appear to be
in the hands of the same party and they
exert a tremendous force in the other
direction and we're seeing that
unfold online over the last 24 hours
right yeah obviously the most you can
ever hope for with regard to
the division in a two-party system
between three branches of government is
two to one
but your point is that so many of the
other forces that are aligned in the
world that are extra governmental
are in fact uh in this living in the
same ideology which is
one that is claiming to be liberal but
that we recognize
as an extremist branch um that is
also authoritarian authoritarian
authoritarian it's an authoritarian
branch
of the democratic party that is
ascending
rapidly it is ascending rapidly and so i
want to make a last point
one of the things that is so troubling
about the way
the tech platforms work and the way it
is interfacing
with this um this power grab and this uh
shoving large numbers of people out the
door is that the way they shove you out
the door
obliterates what you did when you were
there and so it makes a
the history impossible or nearly
impossible to recover
that is to say you know initially
facebook when you
decided that it was too toxic and you
left it disappeared you from all the
conversations that you had been in and
untagged you in every photograph that
you had once been tagged in
and this was a disincentive for people
to leave but now this is turning into a
mechanism
for uh allowing one side to shape the
narrative
falsely right so um
it is difficult i don't know what the
president's
sympathies are i don't trust him and
i think he uh did encourage
um a the protest at the capitol in fact
it's clear that he
encouraged it and what he thought of
those who broke in i
i can't say but there is a question
about whether or not he actually
encouraged the breaking of
the law that is much harder to establish
because he was clearly abiding by
at least a technical standard with
respect to what he said but having
disappeared him from twitter
what you get is the absence of the
evidence that women ordinarily want to
go
through in order to figure out if what
nancy pelosi is saying that he said
actually came out of his mouth at some
point or so my point is that the
very fact of the tech platforms not only
having the ability to prevent you from
speaking going forward but to
effectively erase what you have
said and therefore allows your
detractors to
imply that you have said things that you
may or may not have actually said
that is a very dangerous process and
yeah and it's one with which we should
be well familiar from 20th century
history
from orwell's uh dystopian vision of
20th century history
uh and and more yeah yes the the
airbrushing people
uh out of photographs um is is not a
legitimate process under any
circumstances
right um can we finish by talking a
little bit about
fear and how to overcome it and i feel
like you've
you have you've spent a lot of time
there but um
tiknot han who's a buddhist monk
and has written several books including
this 2012 book called fear
essential wisdom for getting through the
storm um
is really an extraordinary extraordinary
man and i was lucky enough to spend
a couple of weeks with him back in high
school actually
um i had a creative writing teacher
peter levitt who was a poet and also a
buddhist who invited me to this retreat
at this school that
school where we met actually where we
were friends at the time
and it was otherwise felt i was by far
the youngest person there
it was filled with beat poets and an
occasional ceramicist
and and painter and uh
and and me this high school kid aspiring
writer at the time
uh and tiknot han who i had never heard
of before and he
led us this is at a retreat center in
ojai california
he led us in three sitting and one
walking meditations every day
for uh for two weeks and uh
slept in tents and did our art our
writing
and um cooked together and you know in
some ways
it was i think it actually helped me
form my idea for field trips later on
when we would be
um when both of us came to teach as
professors at evergreen but
just a very brief two-page excerpt from
this book in a chapter called the
opposite of fear
two little sections deep listening and
loving speech
when communication is cut off we all
suffer
when no one listens to us or understands
us we are like bombs ready to explode
compassionate listening brings about
healing sometimes only 10 minutes of
listening deeply can transform us and
bring a smile back to our lips
many of us have lost our capacity for
listening and using loving speech in our
families
it may be that no one is capable of
listening to anyone else
so we feel very lonely even within our
own families we go to a therapist hoping
that she will be able to listen to us
but many therapists also have deep
suffering within sometimes they cannot
listen as deeply as they would like
so if we really love someone we need to
train ourselves to be deep
listeners we also need to train
ourselves to use loving speech
we have lost our capacity to say things
calmly we get irritated too easily
every time we open our mouths our speech
is sour or bitter
we have lost our capacity for speaking
with kindness without this ability we
cannot succeed in restoring harmony love
and happiness
in buddhism we speak of bodhisattvas
wise and compassionate beings who stay
on earth to alleviate the suffering of
others
the bodhisattva avalo kachevara
also called kuan yin has a great
capacity for listening with compassion
and true presence
kuan yin is the bodhisattva who can
listen and understand the sounds of the
world the cries of suffering
you have to practice breathing mindfully
in and out so that compassion always
stays with you
you listen without giving advice or
passing judgment you can say to yourself
about the other person
person i am listening to him just
because i want to relieve his suffering
this is called compassionate listening
you have to listen in such a way that
compassion remains with you the whole
time you are listening
that is the art if halfway through
listening
irritation or anger comes up then you
cannot listen deeply anymore you have to
practice in such a way that every time
the energy of irritation
anger comes up you can breathe in and
out mindfully and continue to hold
compassion within you
no matter what the other person says
even if there is a lot of injustice in
his way of seeing things
even if he condemns or blames you you
continue to sit very quietly
breathing in and out if you are not in
good shape if you don't feel that you
can go on listening in this way let the
other person know
ask your friend dear one can we continue
in a few days
i need to renew myself i need to
practice so that i can listen to you in
the best way i can
practice more walking meditation more
mindful breathing and more sitting
meditation to restore your capacity for
compassionate listening
walking with the sangha one wonderful
thing to do with your community is
walking meditation
when we are physically active together
moving it is easy to feel supported by
the collective energy
it is good to begin your practice of
walking meditation with a group to get
the support
you can ask a friend to go with you or
you can even take the hand of a child
and walk with him or her to practice
mindful walking on your own you can
begin by making a contract with a
staircase
you vow that you will always go up or
down that staircase mindfully with very
solid steps
if it happens that halfway up you
realize that one of your steps didn't
have your true presence in it
you go down and begin again you'd end up
on that staircase a very long time
if you can do it successfully with that
staircase then wherever you go
you'll be able to dwell in the present
moment you also can make a contract with
a particular distance perhaps from your
work area to the restroom
and vow that when you walk that distance
every step will be solid and mindful
otherwise you will go back and do it
again it's a wonderful way to learn how
to live every moment of your daily life
deeply
resisting being carried away by your
habit energy walk with your feet
not with your head bring your attention
to your feet and walk
walk in such a way that joy and real
life are possible right here and
now when we do walking meditation as a
group we produce a collective energy of
mindfulness and peace that nourishes us
and helps heal us so that's
obviously in a language that we don't
tend to use between us
or or here on dark horse but um
i think he is he is approaching through
buddhism
what i in particular approached you know
having having learned from him when i
was very young uh through animal
behavior
the act of of going outside of being
present in your body of being
understanding that you are a physical
being uh with instantiation in the real
world
and observing without interpretation as
much as possible
be in your body first and
this isn't something that you will be
doing all the time and it will get in
the way of analysis and interpretation
and creativity to some degree but
especially
when you're hot when you're emotionally
hot as i think almost all of us
are at least sometimes now given what is
going on
being able to return back to self
and physical reality and breathing and
trying to just observe or hear or
be in a place without interpretation is
a
way to reduce fear
yes i think it's it's excellent and uh
tuning in
you know tuning into your environment
and tuning in to
others who are tuned into their
environment is in some sense
uh the antidote and you know as is so
often the case with buddhism
you know it takes a while to figure out
why the approach is what it is and what
the what the deeper point is but once
you see it it's
uh it is it's universal um
and i guess uh we're not getting the c
stars we're going to have to do that
next time we have to save c stars we're
going to save c
stars okay so i guess i uh
in light of your reading i would like to
say something to our audience that i
said to my class the last time
i met with them never ever
before uh we were forced to leave
evergreen
we were in a public park actually um
and what i said to them was
pay very close attention to what is
happening
i don't think we will pass this way
again and i think that's
that's where we are something utterly
dramatic
is afoot and how it comes out we do not
know but it certainly makes sense
to note everything because um
this is history happening
that's right that's right
uh so i think we will forego most of the
announcements we would normally make
but we'll say that good conversations
happen on the discord server
which you can find at either of our
patreons and that after a 15-minute
break for those who are watching rather
than
just listening we'll be back to answer
your questions in the second hour
all right be well everyone we'll see you
shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you